from portion sizes to exclusive flavors
we wanted to find out all the
differences between Prime in the US and
the UK this is food
Wars let's start with prime hydration in
the UK it comes in a 500ml bottle you
can either buy this as a single bottle
or as part of a 12pack in the US our
hydration also comes in one size the
16.9 flu ounce bottle or 500 mL you can
get an options of one bottle an eight
pack which you did not get sorry the 12
12 pack and a 15pack variety we also
have Prime energy which in the UK comes
in a
330ml can just like Prime hydration this
either comes as a single can or as part
of a 12pack in the US Prime energy is a
12 fluid ounce can or 355 ml and it
comes in a single can the 12pack and a
24 pack in the US our biggest Prime
hydration single item by volume is this
the 15 drink variety pack total fluid
volume
23.6 fluid ounces or 7500 milliliters
our larer size is a 12-pack of bottles
which adds up to 6 L of prime but that's
still 20% less than the biggest size in
America and if we go on energy drink
uh 24 cans of these energy drinks this
is 288 flid ounces or
8,520 ml our biggest Prime energy item
is again the 12pack but remember the AR
can slightly smaller than America's a
12pack of Prime energy in the UK adds up
to 3,960 ml that's 53.5% smaller than
the biggest size in
America here are almost all of the
exclusive Prime products you can get in
the US you can't get in the UK and here
are all the prime drinks you'll find in
the UK but not in the US there aren't
any sorry guys there are currently seven
flavors of prime hydration available in
the UK however all of them are available
in the US as well so none of them are
actually exclusive that said there are
some subtle differences in ingredients
when it's compared to the US and also
I've never had prime before so I want to
try all of these give you my thoughts
and maybe rank them as well here are
currently three of the four Prime
hydration drinks you can get in the US
you can't get in the UK so we got the
lemonade we got orange we have this LA
Dodgers flavor that might be just
specific to Los Angeles and there's a
grape flavor couldn't get my hands on
and here are all the other flavors you
get in the US we's start down here lemon
lime I mean this is they're just going
into after Gatorade on this one wasn't
it the first Gatorade flavor lemon lime
really sweet wow that's really sweet ice
pop but also this looks like they have
different names but I grew up calling
them Bomb Pops I feel like I'm really
tasting the Cherry in this one I think
everyone has tried these is said it
these are very sweet but I kind of
surpris me it's marketed towards kids
another thing I wanted to point out is
that I was able to find ice Pop flavors
both in the UK version and the US
version we're going to get more into
ingredients a little bit later on but
I'll do a very quick taste to to see if
there's any notable differences we'll
start with the UK one and then we'll try
The American version the flavors are
broadly the same but the way that this
one kind of like hits your taste buds is
very different and it's really weird
when you consume a drink obviously like
you want to feel like your thirst has
been
quenched you take a sip and there's
something in here that's like actually
kind of like drying my mouth out almost
I think if I had to pick which one's
prefer it is going to be the UK's and
I'm not just saying that from bias
tropical
punch
what
the all right well that's pretty
embarrassing hope nobody's watching
this I do like that and no no kidding
they're getting progressively better as
we go through Can't Screw Up orange
M yeah this might be my favorite one
this is really good and this doesn't
feel as sweet as the other ones or am I
just getting used to it like like how
your eyes adjust to the dark like my
tongue's adjusting to the sweetness to
of the many sports teams in the world
that have some sort of deal with prime
LA Dodgers is one one of them yeah I've
seen people on eBay bidding a lot for
these
so straight up I don't know what flavor
this is but it's good do you want to try
it my lips did touch it is it too weird
I mean we have a professional
relationship oh my God this is so sweet
oh no I've gotten used to it it's a good
lemonade as far as lemon flavored not
carbonated beverage pretty good I was
also able to get my hands on one of the
American exclusives the lemonade flavor
I'm interested to try this because the
US and UK do have slightly differing
ideas of what lemonade is obviously in
the UK we consider generally lemonade to
be like a carbonated clear beverage like
a Sprite whereas in America it's usually
just kind of like lemon juice sugar and
water combined so it does taste a bit
like you've let like a a Sprite kind of
go flat you can probably keep this one
for the time being guys glow Berry it is
supposed to glow in the dark the the
label not the
beverage what the hell yeah I think
that's the worst one that's really weird
metam moon what is the vibe of this what
about this says like oh that's so
refreshing this tastes the way uh
sunblock smells strawberry watermelon
all right back to things I've heard of
no this tastes exactly like gum
Bubblicious like one of those one of
those like really fruity ones yeah yeah
we're going to start down this end with
glow Berry Flavor now I did have to
Google this to see if glow berries were
an actual Berry or not as far as I can
tell they are not I think it generally
refers to a berry flavor and also the
fact that the bottle is supposed to glow
in the dark I think we should put that
to the test Charlie Hit The Lights
not really glowing is
it my first taste of prime and it's not
blown my socks off to say it's just a
very artificial Berry flavor got a bit
of Tang to it next up we've got
strawberry
watermelon
wow I like that the flavor I get from
that is almost more like a Kind of Blue
Power Aid type flavor according to the
label the ice po flavor is supposed to
taste like cherry lime and blue
raspberry yeah I mean so far the vibe
I'm getting is that they all just taste
kind of artificial fruit but I think in
terms of like balancing the flavors this
one's done a pretty good job so far
maybe the most uh delicately balanced
flavor of the lot next up we've got meta
Moon obviously I don't know what the
moon tastes like and I don't know what
the meta tastes like right now either if
there were a food Wars meta yellow
number five would be S tier right
now label just says this is candy
flavored which doesn't fill me with
confidence cuz like which candy tastes
like Mark
Zuckerberg oh it doesn't taste like it
smells no like at least these ones have
had like a fairly identifiable fruity
flavor whereas this one is just kind of
like generic sweet thing then we're on
to blue raspberry and one thing that's
immediately stuck out to me is the color
I think I was actually expecting this to
be like a more bright blue color but
it's actually just kind of white it's
quite a gentle blue raspberry I want a
bit more acidity from that I think but
it goes down very smoothly I do feel
like I'm giving Prime way too much
credit here I'm swilling it around in a
glass like I'm a
samier yeah maybe if we had a decanter I
could pour it out let it breathe a
little bit drinking too much prime I'm
going to be hydrated as hell I'm getting
hopped up on Prime I need to go do like
a celebrity boxing match or something
you and Jo celebrity boxing let's make
thaten yeah Joe you down you and me in
the ring the full 12 rounds I actually
didn't he' win that the fight between me
and Joe you back me Charlie backs me
Harry's Vibe is very like they really
like always just like calm and reserved
or whatever but that kind of like that
sarcasm that they have over there to me
says that like something's going on
underneath the surface that they're
suppressing so Harry St the type of guy
that if he got like into a fight fight
he would like just like black out and
then come to at like in the middle of
the field at midnight with a shovel
covered in blood with a corpse in his
trunk I'll box him as long as it's
supervised moving swiftly on from me and
Jo Fighting next up we've got tropical
punch
Prime so while I was out in the US
recently I was able to try Hawaiian
Punch and that's basically exactly what
I'm getting from this and then finally
we've got the lemon lime flavor of all
of these flavors this is the one that
tastes the most like it supposed to if I
had to rank them I think I'd do it in
the following order I think my least
favorite probably metam moon right in
the middle here metam moon is down there
I think with ice pop they've just tried
to combine a bunch of flavors of don't
necessarily work together very well so I
think it's actually going to be my
second to last I think blue raspberry is
going to come next for me and they lose
points cuz I didn't even try and color
it I think next is going to be glow
Berry the bottle didn't really glow so
maybe uh leave it in the sun for a bit
longer if you going try that at home I
think next up we're going to have
tropical punch my number two is lemon
lime which means that my number one
strawberry watermelon my favorite is the
orange in second place I like the Dodger
flavor actually I think about it I'm
going to go here yeah lemon is good and
from here on ice pop uh I mean yeah
lemon l these these were all like I'd
grab any one of these these three I say
ski a little bit of flavor tweaking or
balancing might go a long way I think
with some of these you wanted like maybe
a bit more Tang to them bit more acidity
maybe dial back of the sweetness on one
or two as well I don't know if I would
necessarily pick a prime over a classic
energy drink like a power aid but I do
think in general if I wanted a sports
drink and I went into a store and this
was all they had I think I'd still be
happy to buy one but they're all fine
and they kind of do that same job next
up let's take a look at Prime energy now
while the prime hydration drinks are
similar to maybe like a Power Aid these
are much more similar to a classic
energy drink like a Red Bull there is
one exclusive energy drink flavor in the
US you can't get in the UK it is the
original that just was announced this
week couldn't get it anyway here are the
rest yes the UK also has them most of
them are similar to The hydration
flavors but there is a new one orange
mango I'm a bit apprehensive about
trying these cuz I don't drink energy
drinks I don't even drink coffee I only
drink tea and I think one of these
contains about as much caffeine as three
cups of tea so we'll start with ice pop
Chin Chin I think that does mirror the
flavor of the hydration drink pretty
closely but I will say tastes better
than like a standard Red Bull flavor
strawberry watermelon I think there
might be a theme here they just kind of
taste like fizzy versions of that here's
the new one orange mango I get mostly
mango I'm not getting much Orange from
that yeah not far off like a Rubicon
tropical punch is up next yeah I think
that one's actually improved by becoming
an energy drink lemon lime you could
give me a glass of that and a glass of
Sprite and I'd struggle to tell the
difference I think cuz it is just again
like a carbonated lemon and lime
beverage blue
raspberry I actually think for a few of
these just carbonating them has actually
made them better I think notably that
was the case with the tropical punch and
also to a degree I think blue raspberry
one I could not get for time of filming
this was the ice pop strawberry
watermelon
though it's like sweet and tart orange
mango uh somehow worse uh-oh so far not
good topical punch
okay yeah one good lemon lime oh yeah
it's pretty good too kind of spr blue
raspberry oo n yeah also like a tart
flavor to it that not that end so I
think I'm going to rank it like this
favorite was lemon lime really enjoyed
the fruit punch glue raspberries like in
the middle and then these two I wouldn't
get I guess W apparently the strawberry
watermelon flavor I'm just not digging
now for the orange mango which was the
worst something about about it just
tastes like an armpit ice pop did not
like that one I'm afraid orange mango
fine but a bit too artificial and there
are I think better like fizzy mango
drinks out there in the UK tropical
punch and blue raspberry were both
improved I think by making them fizzy
but I think just in terms of like Flavor
balance strawberry watermelon
undefeated one thing I will say about
Prime energy is that so far when I've
been tasting these I feel like on the
very rare occasions when I drink like a
r Red Bull or a monster they have kind
of like a very distinct flavor to them
and even if you add flavorings to that
it's hard to mask it completely whereas
I don't really get like a kind of
distinct energy drink flavor throughout
all of these most of them actually do
just kind of taste like fizzy versions
of the hydration drink I think it's
actually quite impressive I think you
probably could drink them almost as a
soda I don't know if that's a good thing
or a bad thing I do think there's still
some room for improvement with the
flavors themselves I think particularly
down this end of course but in general I
think they've done a pretty good job
with the flavor one product that we have
exclusively here in the US are these
Prime hydration plus sticks these are
like the hydration flavors we had but in
powder form I think you can get it in
almost every single flavor I got two for
six of the crowd got six
sticks
okay I mean it looks lemon ly too I
guess probably you're supposed to shake
it up and this way do a water bottle in
a cup cuz like look it's all like
globula at the top here
oh very strong think I could have cut it
with more water but oh
God yeah it's pretty close I mean this
is obviously stronger cuz it's not as
much water sadly the prime hydration
plus sachet have not hit UK shelves just
yet although I can't say I'm too mad
about that I feel like just by the drink
it's
fine the price of prime can vary wildly
depending on where or when you were
looking on the official UK website a
12pack of prime hydration sells for
£24.99 that's around $31 82 the per
buffle cost on the website therefore is
just over2 in the US that same pack is
$29.99 or £
2356 so not much of a price difference
if you're not aware Prime is a brand of
hydration and energy drinks promoted by
the influencers Logan Paul and KSI the
two have amassed a huge fan base online
through various Ventures on YouTube and
podcasting music and even wrestling the
prime is manufactured by Congo brza a
company based out of Louisville Kentucky
Paul and KSI are the primary
spokespeople for the brand when Prime
launched over a year ago with KSI and
Logan Paul putting their celebrity
weight behind the promotion of the brand
it was a huge success however due to the
popularity of the drink a huge reselling
Market has emerged Prime came to the UK
in June 2022 and was an immediate smash
hit on release britz saw teenagers
queuing up outside supermarkets all
morning to try and get their hands on
some places like Asda sold out so
quickly that they had to implement a
three bottle per customer limit
convenience stores realized they could
buy Prime in bulk and flip individual
bottles for a huge markup some such as
the Tik Tok famous wakey wines achieved
infamy when they were caught selling
bottles or cans for as much as 100 each
KSI even had to step in at one point and
scold resellers saying that it was not
ethical uh it wasn't as bad over here it
did fly off the shelves for a little bit
but I think it might have something to
do with the resale value of these online
was pretty good I've never seen anyone
drinking it and to be honest I got
everything at Target and online kind of
no problem now currently the LA Dodgers
limited edition bottles are pretty
pricey on eBay I'm assuming once again
that has more to do with its scarcity
than its taste even now as we film this
in October 2023 the prime Market hasn't
exactly calmed all the way down for some
of the more standard flavors the supply
has now caught up with demand and you're
able to find them in most supermarkets
for the standard retail price for
example I was able to find the bottle of
strawberry watermelon in Tesco for just
£2 however for some of the more exotic
flavors the only places you can find
them are specialist candy shops or Niche
resellers the only place I could find my
bottle of glow bberry was is at one of
those weird American candy stores which
plague Central London this one bottle
cost me
£18 I wouldn't have paid £18 for bottle
of prime but you did expensive so you
didn't pay for it either what is the
most I would realistically pay for a
bottle of prime hydration I don't know
five bucks you think five is high how
much would you pay I've just been
informed $5 is too high 150 you can't
get anything for $150 what are you
talking about fine I would pay as much
as Gatorade and Power Aid and all the
other AIDS are for this it's hard to
find empirical evidence as to whether or
not the craze around Prime has kind of
died down but just from anecdotal
evidence I really don't think it has
even when I was out buying the prime for
this episode I would see kids in the
stores just taking selfies with bottles
of prime like it was a celebrity I think
due to the scarcity and the demand it's
almost become like a status symbol among
certain generations of kids it's a race
to see who can get the new flavors of
prime the fastest people will I guess
empty them out and just use them as like
water bottles when they go to school and
again it's just kind of like a way to
flex on your peers besides converting
their massive fan bases into loyal
customers KSI and Logan Paul have also
been able to translate this into
commercial Partnerships Prime is now an
official drink supplier of the UFC the
LA Dodgers and Arsenal of which I
believe KSI is a fan and they're also
the official sports drink partners of FC
Barcelona and FC Bayern Munich we've
seen other influencers capitalize on
their success in the food and beverage
Space Mr Beast of course says Beast
burger and his chocolate bars Feasta
bles and the Chamberlain has her coffee
brand Chamberlain coffee now according
to Paul in the first year the brand has
cleared 250 million in retail sales
goodness here are all the ingredients
for a prime hydration ice pop flavor in
the UK these are the US hydration ice
Pop ingredients the ingredients are
pretty similar overall the UK has
slightly more coconut water 10.5%
compared to America's 10% but ours is
actually reconstituted from a powder
whereas America's is from concentrate
Prime hydration in both countries boasts
zero add sugar but does contain
artificial sweeteners sucos and aclame
no that's not it as asame k or a
according to the Center for Science in
the public interest a raises health
issues such as cancer hormone disruption
and potential pregnancy risks per health
line there is also evidence suggesting
that aceto acetamide a compound formed
in the body during the breakdown of a
may result in thyroid damage in lab
animals ironically enough the lack of
sugar may be an issue for the the very
purpose of prime hydration electrolytes
play a crucial role in making sure your
body functions properly when you
exercise or play hard you sweat you lose
not just water but you also lose
important electrolytes electrolytes are
key to hydration and Prime does contain
electrolytes like magnesium and
potassium but the low amount of glucose
May impair your body from properly
absorbing the electrolytes as glucose is
useful in transporting them to your
cells to be clear you don't need glucose
to absorb electrolytes but it does help
Prime energy is currently in hot water
with the media as well as the US
government because of its perceived
excessive levels of caffeine here in the
UK our Prime energy cans contain 140 Mig
of caffeine to put that into perspective
a grande coffee from Starbucks contains
around 136 energy cans in the US however
contain 200 Mig of caffeine which is a
42.9% increase from the UK can because
of this Prime is currently experiencing
a significant amount of backlash
resulting in some shops actually pulling
it from shelves in order to protect kids
health in July of this year Senator
Chuck Schumer called for an F 8 probe of
prime and said it was a cauldron of
caffeine that posed serious health
concerns for Kids One Prime energy
contains 20000 Mig of caffeine which is
about as much caffeine in a sixpack of
Coke does it right there on legally the
smallest font you could put it in
however looking at the caffeine amounts
of some other drinks currently on the
market in the US paints a slightly
different picture let's be clear 200 Mig
in this can is a lot of caffeine
pound-for-pound it contains more
caffeine than Monster Energy or Red Bull
but other American drinks such as bang
energy or Celsius heat contain 300 Mig
per can that's 50% more than Prime we
don't have these in the UK I never had
of Bango Celsius energy and they sound
terrifying one distinction that Senator
Schumer is highlighting is that Prime is
aimed at a kids Market despite the fact
that the can says not for children under
the age of 18 now if that is the case
Prime still isn't the biggest offender
gu fuel a brand that appears to also
appeal to kids specifically in the
gaming space has several drinks with 300
Mig of caffeine they got flavors like
rainbow sherbet snow cone hype sauce
that contain more caffeine than a prime
as well celebrity branded flavors from
PewDiePie and someone or something
called One Shot girl both have 300 mgs
of caffeine in the can where's the
outrage for
that a bottle of ice pop Prime hydration
in the US contains all of this in the UK
a bottle of ice pop Prime hydration
contains the following so in the UK our
Prime has slightly more calories but
less sodium if you grab yourself a Prime
energy I have the lemon lime flavor it
contains all of this in the UK the same
drink orbe it in a slightly smaller can
contains the following so it's almost
identical to Americas although we have a
little bit more sodium Charlie's
correctly pointed out that sachet would
be way better for the environment CU
you're not using plastic waste so maybe
I just hate the planet I'm sorry uh
Greta thunberg and polar bears it's not
personal so am I going to make money
flipping this on Facebook or what